The Economist suppose countries were
like people and could shift from one
neighborhood to another Britain for
example humbled by it dire public
finances could move closer to southern
Europe for example to a new position
near Madeira a bumpy journey there might
have another good side effect allowing
Wales and Scotland to become separate
islands in Britain's place should come
Poland which has suffered quite enough
in its location between Russia and
Germany and deserves a chance to enjoy
the bracing winds of the North Atlantic
and the security of seawater between it
and any potential invaders Belgium's
incomprehensible Dutch french-language
squabbles a redolent of Central Europe
at its worst
especially the nonsenses that Slovakia
thinks up for it's Hungarian speaking
ethnic minority so Belgium should swap
places with the Czech Republic the
stolid well-organized Czechs will get on
splendidly with their new Dutch
neighbours and vice-versa Estonia Latvia
and Lithuania should move to a new
location somewhere near Ireland like
Ireland they've bitten the bullet of
internal devaluation regaining
competitiveness by cutting wages and
prices rather than taking the easy
option of depreciating the currency or
borrowing recklessly as Greece has the
Baltics would also be glad to be farther
away from Russia and closer to America
Deloris currently landlocked and trying
to wriggle out from under Russia's thumb
would benefit greatly from
exposure to the Nordic region its
influence played a big role in helping
the Baltics shed their Soviet legacy so
Belarus should move northwards to the
Baltic taking the place of Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania Kaliningrad could
shift up the coast towards Russia proper
while the western and central parts of
Ukraine should move into slots for cated
by Poland and Belarus Germany with the
Ukrainian border now in near hundred
kilometers from Berlin would start
having to take that country's European
integration seriously some reordering of
the Balkans is long overdue to Macedonia
Albanian Kosovo should all rotate places
with Macedonia taking Kosovo's place
next to Serbia Kosovo moving to Albania
slot on the coast and Albania shifting
in
and paranoid Greek fantasies about
territorial claims from the deluded Slav
irredentist in the nameless northern
neighbor would be even more
unsustainable he would also make sense
to move Switzerland north where I would
fit neatly into the Nordic countries its
neutrality would go down well with the
Finns and Swedes Norway would be glad to
have another non EU country next door
Austria could shift westwards into
Switzerland place making room for
Slovenia and Croatia to move Northwest
too they could join northern Italy in a
new regional alliance ideally it would
be run by Doge from Venice the rest of
Italy from Rome downwards would separate
and join with Sicily to form a new
country officially he might be called
the kingdom of Two Sicilies some unkind
people quite unfairly might give it
another nickname such as bordello
of course the moves don't create a
perfect fit so welcome side effect would
be to make space for previously
fictional creations such as Antony hopes
Rory Tanya as J's Seldovia and borduria
and Vulgaria the backdrop for
chitty-chitty-bang-bang European
geography can be as frustrating as the
continents history or the more reason
therefore to daydream when you can